[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions our phone line are open if you
have a Bible related question give us a
call now at 800 God says that's 800 463
7297 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Doug Bachelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact during his travels in 1298
Marco Polo spoke of a bird in Madagascar
that was so big it could knock over an
elephant through 300 years later early
Arabian explorers returned from the
coast of East Africa with accounts of
gigantic Birds three times as big as an
ostrich at first their stories were
dismissed as fables but then they
brought evidence huge eggs up to 3 feet
in circumference they were indeed the
eggs of a giant flightless bird from the
island of Madagascar that would thanks
to Marco Polo become known as the
elephant bird or epuris Maximus the
elephant bird now extinct was the
largest bird that has ever lived it's
estimated to have weighed up to 1,00 LBS
and stand up to 11 ft tall the last
sighting of a live bird was in 1649
shortly after the French settled in
Madagascar the early natives described
the elephant bird as a shy giant that
was probably driven to extinction by
people raiding their nest for the
extraordinary eggs one of the largest
intact specimens is 35 in in
circumference around its long axis and
probably had a capacity of more than 2
gallons I was calculating Pastor Ross
that would probably be about 150 omelets
from one egg it was much bigger than any
dinosaur egg that's ever been discovered
in fact some biologists calculated that
these eggs of the elephant birds were
the largest examples of a single cell to
have ever existed on Earth it sad with
such an epic creature goes extinct but
the Bible says that someday all the
wicked are going to be extinct and the
Beautiful Creatures are going to be
restored that's right Pastor Doug you
know talking about a big bird of course
you mentioned ostriches and and they are
big you've seen them I've been in Africa
we've gotten up close to ostriches
actually I've I've ridden an ostrich
before but to imagine a bird this size
as described yet it would be really neat
to have been able to see it but I think
the last sighting you said was in the
1600s 16 I think about
1649 and you know in the pictures that
we just showed for those who are
watching the video of the radio program
there was actually a picture of a very
young David Attenborough holding one of
the eggs that they had kind of pieced it
back together from a broken specimen
they you know they're out in the desert
and it's calcium and it lasts for
hundreds of years so they put one back
together and they're just absolutely
enormous and they believe this is where
the Arabian Legend of what they called
The Rock The ROC it was his giant bird
uh that's where those Legends came from
so there really were some meapa big
birds that's where Sesame Street got it
huh that used to live but you know the
Bible tells us that uh someday the
wicked will be extinct and all of the
beautiful animals restored and God's
going to make a new Heaven new Earth you
know it says blessed are the meek they
will inherit the earth you can read in
Psalm 37:35 and 36 I've seen the wicked
in great power and spreading himself
like a native green tree yet he passed
away and behold he was no more indeed I
sought him but he could not be found
someday it tells us all the wicked are
going to be gone and God's going to
create a new Heaven A New Earth and
friends that's why Jesus came he wants
you to be in that Kingdom with him and
he's prepared a mansion for you and we
have a book that talks about it if you'd
like to know more about the home that
God has prepared for is saved our book
free offer is called Heaven is it for
real and of course it's for anyone who
will call and ask the number to call is
800 835
6747 that is our free offer number just
call that number and ask for Heaven is
it for real if you have your smartphone
handy you can dial pound 250 say Bible
answers live you can also ask for it by
name Heaven is it for real we be happy
to send it to you if you're in the US or
in Canada if you're outside of North
America you you can still receive this
by just going to our website
amazingfacts.org and you'll be able to
read it there well Pastor Doug before we
take our callers we have a number of
folks who are waiting with their Bible
questions let's start with prayer dear
father we thank you that we do have this
time once again to be able to open up
your word and study there is power in
the word and so Lord we just pray for
your blessing be with those who are
listening and pray that you'd guide us
as we search the scriptures together and
we thank you Lord in jesus' name amen
amen amen okay well we're ready to go to
our first Coler we've got Pam listening
in La Pam welcome to Bible answers
live good evening Pastor Doug and Pastor
Ross evening thank you for call my
Call you're welcome my question is is it
okay to pray to the Holy Spirit to ask
the Holy Spirit to lead me and to guide
me well the holy Spirit certainly is God
the spirit you know the father Son and
Holy Spirit all comprise the godhead
sometimes called the Trinity um and I
don't know that there'd be anything
wrong with it but typically in the Bible
uh I you've only got a couple of
examples of people actually praying to
Jesus usually prayers are directed to
the father in jesus' name and um I I'm
trying to think of a prayer to The
Spirit Well it says the spirit and the
bride say come that's not really a
prayer can you I don't know Pastor Ross
I can't think of someone praying
directly to the spirit I don't think so
I mean usually like you say prayers are
directed to the father in The Name of
Christ and we are praying uh asking for
the Holy Spirit but not necessarily
praying directly to the Holy Spirit
although the Holy Spirit the Bible makes
it clear that he does hear our prayers
he does intercede he does move Upon Our
Hearts to reveal to us what we need to
pray but uh I think in the one for
example when Steven was being stoned he
cried out and he prayed prayed Lord
Jesus receive my spirit so there we have
a prayer to Christ but I don't know if
there's a a a mention in in scripture
where it's specifically a pray to the
Holy Spirit no I you know I don't think
there's anything wrong with it I would
you know wonder why would someone want
to as opposed to praying to the father
through Christ or even praying to Jesus
but certainly there's nothing wrong with
praying to the Holy Spirit you know we
do have a book talking about the holy
spirit it's called life in the spirit
and what happy to send this to anyone
who calls and asks the number is 800
83567 47 you can ask for the book it's
called life in the spirit you can also
dial pound 250 on your smartphone say
Bible answers live and then ask for the
book by name life in the spirit thank
you Pam we're gonna go to Jeff in
Washington Jeff you're on Bible answers
live all thank you yeah for taking my
call absolutely thank you I have a
question about I have a question about
uh has something to do with uh Daniel
chapter 9 the 70 we prophecy and also
Daniel chapter 7 verse 25 okay speaks
about this little horn power was to seek
to change times and
laws and because they usurp God's
Authority by removing the 70th week to
an unspecified time you know it's
futurism wouldn't that also be changing
times that's a good point according to
scripture
the you know the beast power is seen in
Daniel chapter 7 also in Daniel chapter
8 for that matter and in Daniel 9 too
it's the early stages of the Beast
anyway um and futurism takes the last
week of Daniel 9 and it just sort of
shifts it down to the end of time and
floats somewhere wherever they want it
to be they'll you know wherever the they
say the secret Rapture will take place
that's when that week begins no example
of car caring up a prophecy like that
and so yeah they are changing a time in
that respect it it also means of course
that the beast power is um establishing
new holy days and moving the standing
holy day so they're taking times and
laws that are holy and shifting them
around but um I'd never thought of that
what do you think yeah I think anytime
you start tampering with the word of God
you're in trouble and especially that
prophecy and what's so beautiful about
the 70 weeks it actually identifies when
Christ would come and it describes his
ministry and talks about his death and
his resurrection then his Ascension the
gospel going out to the Gentile World in
34 ad and the sad thing is they take
that last week and they apply it to an
antichrist power that they believe will
appear in the last seven you know during
the tribulation these seven years of
tribulation but it's not biblical it's
actually a prophecy pointing to Jesus
and they take that same prophecy and
they try and apply it to an antichrist
power at the end it's kind of sad it it
is it's heartbreaking yeah it's an
important prophecy it's a great study we
do have a study guide that talks about
that and it's called right on time and
it deals with the uh the 70 weeks of
Daniel chapter 9 and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number is 8835
6747 you can ask for that study guide
It's called right on time or do pound
250 on your smartphone and ask Bible
answers live and then say right on time
that's the name of the lesson we'll send
it to anyone who calls and asks amen
we've got Britney listening in
California Britany welcome to Bible
answers
live hey hey hi how you doing and your
question
tonight yeah my
questions Revelation
11:19 which says then God's temple in
heaven was opened and within his Temple
was see the Arc of the
Covenant I was wondering how does that
even relate to our time with all the end
times events and and the global outcry
with Israel and just all the crazy going
on with and the end terms events slowly
coming to our heads even with
political crazy with the president and
government and all the well this
particular yeah let me read this verse
Britney for our friends that are
listening it says and then the temple of
God was open in heaven and the Ark of
his Covenant was seen in the temple and
there were Lightnings noises thunderings
and earthquake and great hail now
looking other places in Revelation just
before the second coming there's
lightning noises thunderings earthquake
and a great hail talks about a great
hail Paul's falls upon the wicked it's
not so much the ark as what's in the ark
the ark is a container for the law of
God and it tells us that you know at the
end the law of God is going to be
exalted when something's in heaven it's
interesting Pastor Ross Jesus said
Heaven and Earth would have to pass away
before one tit of the law would fail and
that's because man can't take away the
heavens and there's a copy up there
anyway the heavens will be open it's
there but um there may be some prophetic
significance here what do you think yeah
I mean the whole passage you read
Revelation chapter 11 uh it talks about
the sounding of the seventh trumpet
there's actually several themes that you
find in Revelation 11 it talks about the
two witnesses and then following that
talks about the sounding of the seventh
trumpet and uh talks about the Nations
being angry in the time of the Dead that
they should be judged and then it says
and I saw the Ark of the Covenant in
heaven so this is a description of an
event described in heaven the sounding
of the seventh trumpet really
historically began uh at the end of the
2300 days which is 1844 we don't have
time to get into all the details but uh
we're living in that special end time
period and it's interesting in 1844
shortly thereafter there was a
significant year not only religious but
also in scientific advancements a very
interesting study just the year 1844 but
after that people began to study the
word of God they began to realize the
importance of the Ten Commandments not
that we are saved through obedience to
the Ten Commandments but we are saved in
order to obey and they realized the
fourth Commandment the one that has to
do with the Sabbath so right around that
time um the law of God was been studied
the word has been studied the second
coming and it all ties into what we read
about under the seventh trumpet yeah
it's also uh I think it hearkens back to
when on the seventh day they marched
around the city seven times they blew
seven trumpets and the last that last
trumpet was the fall of Jericho and
God's people taking the promised land so
uh you're you're seeing that this is
what's happening just before we get to
go to the promised land so well good
question thank you Britney we've got
Gary listening in Illinois Gary welcome
to the
program thank you yeah thing that we're
already experiencing prophecy come true
in climate change and political perilous
times when practicing the Great
Commission uh be the most important
expectation from
God yeah you know Jesus said the gospel
of this Kingdom this is Matthew 24:14
the Gospel of this Kingdom will be
preached in all the world for a witness
that's the Great Commission and then the
end will come it's interesting you would
uh mention what you said about what's
going on with the political unrest and
the the world we just read that there
from Revelation 11 where it said the
nations are angry your time of your
wrath has come that the dead should be
judged and you'll destroy those who
destroy the Earth and you we see a big
uptick of War right now and War on a
level that uh more sophisticated man
gets with artificial intelligence and
the Weaponry it becomes more lethal and
uh yeah you just wonder how much longer
can't be much longer before Jesus comes
but yeah we should be emphasizing the
Great Commission thank you Gary
appreciate that all right we got Bruce
listening in North Carolina Bruce
welcome to the
program hello pastors I got um this will
be fast I got two
questions
what Bible programs do you two
personally use logos is my go-to but I
also have es sword and my second
question is is when I watch Pastor Doug
preach he's got
stickers on the inside cover of his
Bible I just wonder how he used them or
what were they for yeah okay two good
practical questions uh yeah Pastor Ross
and I use logos um I I use logos quite a
bit and I also use es sword that's a
free program you can download on our
phones in fact we were sharing that this
week with our church members to
encourage them to read through the Bible
uh on our phones uh
we've got esort has a phone application
the Blue Letter Bible Olive Tree is
another good program and then if you're
studying the Bible on the internet
there's Bible Gateway and all of them
have reading through the Bible apps
where you can read through the Bible and
what was the one you use for reading out
loud called dwell dwell and yeah Bible
reading program you also an app but you
know they are different there are some
free resource of course if one has logos
it is it does cost and depending which
version you have you can spend quite a
bit of money
it's very in-depth and it has a lot of
of features but there are other free
programs I think Esa it is one that uh
you can really have a great study and
it's got the strong concordance you can
look up different translations you you
can search a word in the original
language so there's there's a number of
great features to help in Bible study
and the the little tabs you see when I'm
preaching I just I buy these at uh
Walmart they little markers and it helps
me quickly find a passage in my Bible
and I usually print my scriptures that
I'm going to read in the front of my
Bible because when you're doing
television time is very important very
valuable you spend a lot of money for a
minute and so I try not to waste a lot
of time turning Pages while people are
just waiting I have it all ready to go
too quickly so I I pre-mark things I
know I'm going to read in advance thanks
nice practical question Bruce we' got
Glenn listening in Ohio Glenn welcome to
Bible answers
live well good evening and thank you for
taking my call thank you Glenn in the
Bible there's the parable of the talents
where a person was given 10 talents
another person five talents and the
third person one talent and as time and
went on they were questioned about what
they did with their talents and the the
10 talents and five talents they
invested them or put their talents at
risk MH and they were given a bountiful
increase the person with the one
Talent uh did not invest his and not
only did he lose that talent but he he
ended up with
nothing so we're talking about investing
and as and gambling there's a situation
where
someone pastors they the board puts
money aside for their Pastor for their
retirement and they invest that money
they put that money at risk in a stock
market then we have
so are you're wondering if there's
something wrong with investing in a
mutual fund or the stock market or
something or is that gambling is that
the question put when you putting your
money at risk is what I'm talking about
then there's somebody who wants to play
the lottery and they put their dollar in
by a lottery ticket and they call that
gambling and I was just thinking the the
Bible kind of
exonerates investing your money but what
the person that is
buying a lotto ticket investing in a
Lotter in a lottery ticket yeah that's a
good question he's using the baby's milk
money I think that that may be the
difference between an investment and and
gambling if you use the baby's milk
money wherever you use it does that make
sense well I think I understand the
question but um there is a big
difference between playing the lottery
now if you're gambling if you go to a
casino or you're playing the lottery
your chances of winning uh you've got a
better chance of getting struck by
lightning it's very very remote and if
you go gamble we know that the casinos
exist because The House Always Wins very
few people come away uh in the long term
with money from a casino they usually
lose when you're investing carefully in
the the stock market which is what banks
do banks are always investing in stocks
and bonds or treasuries whatever uh over
time the value of real estate it goes up
and down but long haul it goes up it's a
much much safer investment and when
Jesus talks about them investing you
could even you know put your money in
the bank and you'll get at least minimal
savings and that's why Jesus said well
you could have at least the UN what do
you call the lazy servant he said you
could have at least given it to the
bankers and gotten interest so God
expects us to invest and trade and grow
he wants us to do it wisely I I had a
friend who's a farmer he said farming's
a gamble mhm you know we'd all starve if
they didn't do it so usually it pays off
but sometimes you have a bad year and
you can have losses you can have seven
years of plenty and a few years of of
want so the Lord wants us to invest and
use good judgment but when you get in
the realm of gambling it's just Reckless
speculation and that that I think the
Bible
condemns okay thank you Glenn we've got
um Lee listening in Texas Lee you're on
the air welcome to the program yes sir
thank you my question for tonight is are
there other signs a person hasn't done
the apartable
sin yeah what how do we know if a person
has committed the unpardonable sin well
for one thing uh typically they they
don't hear the voice of the Holy Spirit
speaking to them they don't feel a sense
of uh conviction or any desire to repent
and be at peace with God uh and the
devil I think sometimes tries to commit
convince people they've committed the
unpardonable sin when they have
haven't um and they become very
discouraged and hard on themselves and
the devil would like for them to just
give up hope but um God is almost always
willing to forgive a lot more than we're
willing to
ask and um he's very patient now
there'll be a time at the end of time
when Christ stands up and and probation
closes and the saved or saved and the
lost or lost but most of the time if a
person is asking about committed the
unpardonable sin they haven't committed
it because they've got a desire they a
yearning a conviction of the spirit
working in their heart you know we have
a book called um about the unpardonable
sin I'm trying to think what the name of
the book is Passad EG I think it used to
be called Beyond mercy and now it's just
called what is the unpardonable sin
there you go that's easy enough if you'd
like to receive that and learn more the
number to call is 800 83567 47 you can
just ask for the book it's called what
is the unpardonable sin we be happy to
send it to anyone in the US or in Canada
again if you're outside of North America
just visit the website amazingfacts.org
uh next caller that we have is John
listening in Michigan John welcome to
the program well actually it's uh Aon
Aon welcome from New
York good evening pastors
evening Revelation 21 says that there
will be a new Heaven and a new Earth and
the first Heaven and the first Earth
will pass away and that the Tabernacle
of God is with men and he will dwell
with them what I got from this is that
God will leave the heaven where he dwelt
in now and make a new dwelling place on
Earth but someone told me that the first
Heaven and the first the the first
Heaven is only the atmosphere around
Earth and God will never leave his
headquarters from where it is now which
of these two ideas is
right well when John says the first
Heaven and Earth passed away uh the the
Jews had three words they use for heaven
sometimes they use the word heaven and
they're talking about the the air where
the clouds are and the birds fly that's
in Revelation where it says God
separated the waters above from the
waters below and he made a heaven
atmosphere um and they call that the
first Heaven second heaven is where the
stars are third heaven is where God
dwells Paul says I was caught up to the
third heaven um but in Revelation the
context says he when he says first
heaven was passed away he's talking
about the former
the one the earth and the heaven that
existed first is gone so we got a new
atmosphere a new world and God we know
he's going to dwell with men because it
says the New Jerusalem comes down out of
Heaven God is in the city God himself
will dwell with us he's moving the
capital of the universe to our planet
because we're Made In His Image and we
will dwell with him so I think it's
pretty clear that God is going to
ultimately move Christ has become a
human he's joined himself forever to our
race and he's going to move down to this
world um yeah that's you'd enjoy the
free offer about heaven is it for real
that we're offering to yeah that one I
thought of another one also called a
colossal City in space there you go
that'd be good talks about Revelation 21
in the New Jerusalem the number to call
for that is 800 835
6747 you can ask for that study guide a
colossal City in space if you haven't
called and asked for the free offer
Heaven is a for real real you can ask
for that as well you can dial pound 250
on your smartphone say Bible answers
live and then just ask for it by name it
is a colossal City in space and Heaven
is it for real we've got John from
Michigan John welcome to the
program Hi how are you thank you for
taking my call I appreciate your show
it's helped me a lot amen thank you um
so my my question is regarding the
Sabbath I've uh you know I grew up
Christian school and just just uh
recently this the Sabbath awareness came
up and my my job has you know they
switched my schedule to where I work
weekends and and nights and I'm having a
hard time making the transition because
I have so many people relying on my
income and I'm just kind of lost oh boy
that that sounds like a challenge well
you know the first thing is and it I'm
not saying it's easy but the first thing
is you have to make up your mind uh am I
committed to obey What God Says whether
it's the Sabbath or any
commandment um and there you know
they'll be pressures Shadrach meach and
abedo were pressured they were going to
lose their job and their lives if they
did not pray to the grave of an image or
bow before it they said we can't do that
and Daniel was going to lose his job and
his life if he prayed to anybody but the
king that would break the first
commandment don't have other gods um you
need courage also in keeping the fourth
Commandment now what to do is you know
you might go to your boss I don't know
all the
circumstances and we can certainly pray
that God will work things out but you
can just tell your boss you know this is
a conviction I'm an honest worker um but
you know I I want to keep my Sabbath
fortunately in North America there are a
number of laws on the book books that um
help people through uh that that guide
employers through to respect the
religious convictions of their employees
now you know some circumstances are
different but um I just have a heart to
heart to write a letter with your boss
see if you can walk in face to face is
better and just tell them why this is
really important to you and it's it's
creating quite a struggle because you
love your job but you love God also and
you want to keep his Commandments and
you know if you are attending a Sabbath
keeping church sometimes you can talk to
the pastor there and I know we've done
it number of times we'll write a letter
on behalf of that person stating that
they do attend regularly it's the day of
worship we you know appreciate their
baross or they work accommodating them
in any way possible and of course you
need to be willing to even work at
different times so that you can get your
Sabbath off yeah very good thank you for
your question John hope that helps a
little bit uh by the way friends we're
not done we're coming back in just a
moment more
questions stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
shortly
the Bible tells us that salvation of
course emanates from God so we need to
know something about God to rightly
understand and embrace salvation yet in
the church today there's a great deal of
confusion about the nature of God the
Bible says God is one God but is he
three persons is Jesus also Eternal God
because Jesus is the son of God does
that mean there was a time when he did
not exist or he was brought into
existence is the holy spirit a person or
is he just the force and the energy that
God uses to communicate you know I
thought this was so important I really
felt led of the Lord to write a book on
the subject called exploring the Trinity
one God or three in this book we answer
those very important questions we talk
about the history of the holy spirit in
the Old Testament as well as the history
of the holy spirit in the church and how
it has been much debated this is
something we really need to understand
because Jesus said eternal life comes
from knowing god
thank you for tuning in to amazing facts
have you ever wanted to study the
teachings of the Bible in an easy to
understand stepbystep way the amazing
facts Bible school offers free simple to
follow lessons that will guide you
through all of the vital teachings of
scripture visit amazing
multiple
languages would you like to have
unlimited free access to a library of
resources that'll help answer your most
important questions about the Bible
amazing facts has a huge collection of
faith-building books covering a whole
spectrum of topics you can download and
read wherever you are in multiple
languages to enjoy our Free Library
visit amazingfacts.org click on the
Bible study Tab and choose free book
Library
Library you're listening to Bible
answers live where every question
answered provides a clearer picture of
God and his plan to save you so what are
you waiting for get practical answers
about the good book for a better life
today if you have a question about the
Bible or living the Christian Life call
us now at 800 God says that
7297 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends to
Bible answers live and some may have
tuned in along the way this is a live
International interactive Bible study
we're so thankful to meet the people
that call in with their questions from
around the world and uh we'll do our
best to see if we can find biblical
answers for you regarding the word of
God or the Christian Life my name is
Doug Bachelor my name is Jean Ross and
Pastor Doug it's nice to also greet
those who are joining us online we have
folks who are watching on YouTube also
on Facebook on Amazing Facts TV and so
number of folks tune in every week some
might be watching this after the live
broadcast so we want to greet all of you
um there's something else I was going to
mention yes right here almost forgot we
also want to greet some of those uh
radio stations that have uh taken on
Bible answers live uh this even even
those who are listening on kja a from
Arkansas want to greet you as well as
kfh l in Bakersfield California so
welcome those who are listening and if
you have a Bible question give us a call
the number is
7297 next call is Sam listening in Ohio
Sam welcome to the
program hi pastors hi um my my question
is from Luke chapter 21 and verse
24 okay the end of that verse says
Jerusalem will be trampled by Gentiles
until the times of the Gentiles are
fulfilled and I was wondering what this
times of the Gentiles
means yeah well that is a that is a
great question it's also um the answer
has different advocates for different
views and it could actually be one of
the examples of a dual prophecy where
there's more than one um so it's very
clearly talking about that Jerusalem
right on the surface you see the
disciples had asked Jesus he said there
would not be one stone left upon another
in the temple so the contexts of his
answer he's talking about the temple
being destroyed the Romans destroying
Jerusalem the Jews being carried off in
captivity especially in Luke as Luke on
the way to the Cross Jesus tells the
women don't cry for me but cry for
yourselves because uh you know you'll
say blessed are the baren that did not
bear so he was telling the people in
Jerusalem that judgment was coming and
so it says Jerusalem would be trotten by
the Gentiles well that happened the
Romans took it and it bounced around
between the Crusaders and the Arabs and
everybody in between and the English
until Miracle of Miracles
1948 they uh became an independent
nation again so I think right on the
surface historically you see something
happening here but then there's those
who say uh Jerusalem being trodden by
the Gentiles is also talking about the
persecution of the church and the
ultimate liberation of the New Jerusalem
and victory over the evil
so you know it could mean both and uh I
don't know you if you have any thoughts
on that Pastor I agree I think I think
it's definitely it just seems just
reading it as it is talking about
literal Jerusalem talking about the
literal destruction in 70 AD MH and it's
talking about the Gentiles until their
time be fulfilled and historically we
can see yes that did occur the Jews are
back in Jerusalem back in Israel but
yeah there could be a broader
application as you mentioned a spiritual
connection there thank you Maya hope
that helps a little bit we got Susie
listening in California Susie welcome to
the
program hello good evening pastors
evening and thank you for taking my call
my question is can I be saved without
reading my Bible because one of my
church leader he told me that Bible can
save me
well you know what we're saved by is
Faith In Jesus and the Bible says faith
comes by hearing and hearing by the word
of God now back when Paul wrote that not
everybody could read but some could and
everyone could hear with the few
exceptions of people that were deaf and
so it's saying that you know as we read
and or hear the word of God there's
power in his word if a person's not able
to read um maybe maybe they can hear it
read fortunately today there's a lot of
different apps where the Bible can read
to you or you can find you know apps and
things that'll read the Bible but the
Bible keeps us from sin the Bible shows
us the the character of Christ Jesus is
revealed in the word and so it's you
know I can't understate the importance
of the word of God to both bring us
conviction and comfort with the Holy
Spirit speaking through it so am I
answering what you're
asking
Susie can you hear me yeah uh so should
I read should I continue to read my by
Bible should you what now I couldn't
hear that should I continue to read my
Bible there
absolutely yeah yeah was I was confused
about my one of my you know my church
leaders she told he told me about that
and know the what did the leader tell
you not to read your
Bible yeah because he cannot save me it
cannot save me my Bible canot save me
well you know if you've got a church
leader telling you not to read your
Bible I'd be looking for another
church um the yeah Christ is revealed
through the word the Bible's the
foundation for what we believe God
speaks to us through his word we are
saved because of what we read in the
word and faith in it so uh in many ways
it's the word that saves us and reading
the Bible like I said can't be saved
without faith and faith comes by hearing
the word and when Jesus was tempted he
our example he quoted from scripture he
said it is written it is written so he
read the word revelation the last book
of the Bible says blessed is He who
reads and those who hear the words of
this prophecy and keep those things yeah
which are written therein so for a
Christian one who is able to read the
word they need to read the word matter
of fact when the word is read they
usually follows a Revival for example
the Protestant Reformation when they
were able to translate the Bible into
the language of the common people there
was a Revival that took place so there's
power in the
absolutely yeah in fact you know here we
are at the cusp of a new year I know the
producers don't like me to date the
program because it plays all all year
long but this Live program it is the
beginning of a new year we're
encouraging all of our friends and and
members of our church to get into a
Bible reading program read through the
Bible in a year and it just strengthens
your faith all right thank you Susie
we've got uh Robert listening in
Washington Robert welcome to the
program oh Pastor hello Pastor John yeah
you're on the
air hi there hi um hello I was just
wanting to know um I I guess had the
people
uh uh note about Psalms 1 1 through3 I
just was wanting to know if you could
explain that a little bit more like uh
about the Council of the ungodly the
sitting in the or standing in the path
of Sinners and and uh
the the other one um the seed of the if
you could explain that a little bit more
sure yeah we'll take it's a great verse
we'll do our best to quickly expound it
and this is from Psalms the first Psalm
written by David verse 1 to3 blessed is
the man who walks not in the counsil of
the ungodly nor stands in the path of
Sinners nor sits in the seat of the
scornful but his Delight is in the law
of the Lord and in his law he meditates
day and night he will be like a tree
planted by the rivers of water that
brings forth its fruit and season whose
Leaf will not wither and whatsoever he
doth shall prosper So it's talking about
someone that they don't first you notice
they're walking and then they're
standing it's like they're walking by
and then they're standing listening and
ultimately they're sitting when you're
walking by and you see the ungodly keep
walking because if you stand and listen
pretty soon you're sitting with a
scornful it's like a progression and U
it says that we should flee Temptation
walk away from it or actually run from
it like Joseph ran from Piper's wife but
this person they will not walk they will
not stand they will not sit with the
scorners the Sinners the ungodly but
their Delight is the opposite of the
ungodly the law of the Lord the truth
the word of God and they meditate on it
day and night Moses had surround
ourselves with the word of God and then
pictures him as a tree planted in the
wilderness and I used to live in a
desert it was easy to find the Oasis in
the desert because it's the only green
spot if that tree can it can be in a
desert but if it's got a stream of water
by it it will flourish it's got a
continual flow of nourishment and so God
promises that for those that Delight in
his law and turn from sin you know we
have a book I was just thinking about it
for the previous caller but also ties in
with this one it's called the ultimate
resource and it's about the Bible of
course you find the law in the the Bible
so uh all the blessings in studying the
word of God and we'll send this for free
to anyone just call and ask it's called
the ultimate resource it's one of our
books and it's all about the Bible the
number to call is
8835 6747 you can ask for that book all
dial pound 250 on your smartphone and
say Bible answers live and ask for the
ultimate resource we've got who do we
have next let's see we've got
uh uh Jean in Connecticut there we go
Jean welcome to the
program hi uh Pastor Doug Pastor Ross uh
thank you very much for taking my
call yeah your
question yes sorry um I'm asking about
Revelation 11 specifically verse two
okay um I'm just wondering what the holy
city um in uh the verse is referring to
and um and what does it mean when the
outer Temple it's being given to the
Gentiles yeah uh well I'll tell you a
little bit and then Pastor Ross will
pick it up um probably 50% of Revelation
is drawing
from uh the prophets in the Old
Testament namely Zachariah Isaiah
Jeremiah Ezekiel there's a passage in
the end of Ezekiel where Ezekiel is told
to measure a temple and a lot of people
wonder what is this Temple and it was
never built and why was this Temple that
he measures never Built Well you get to
the New Testament Jesus said destroy
this Temple made with hands and I will
make one without hands and he spoke of
his body the church and so the measuring
of the temple is not talking about
measuring bricks up in heaven it's
talking about an evaluation or Judgment
of God's people yeah absolutely and if
you look at it says uh ma of the temple
but leave out the court there were three
parts of the temple you had the
courtyard then you had the holy and you
had the most holy place the courtyard
represents the Earth that's where the
lamb was sacrificed Jesus came to the
Earth he died for our sins he's the Lamb
of God that takes away the sins of the
world but then Christ arose and he
ascended to Heaven There to minister as
our priest our high priest well that
Ministry of the priest was in the holy
and the most holy place after the
sacrifice had been made so when it says
leave out the court it's referring to
the Earth and it says the Gentiles were
treaded under foot for 42 months well
there's an interesting time period there
that's 1,200 60 days there were 30 days
in a Hebrew month you do the math 42 *
30,60 so you've got a time period of
1,260 years one prophetic day equals one
literal Year and that time period
actually met its fulfillment during the
Dark Ages where the truths of Christ's
High Priestly Ministry was been
substituted by man-made Traditions by
the established church but at the end of
that time period in 1798 and then
leading into 1800s you had the
Reformation you had the the word of God
being translated and that really
culminated in the study of the word of
God and the truths of Christ's High
Priestly Ministry so that that's also
reference to that 1260 or 42 months time
period that you read about in that verse
yeah I think our lesson that talks about
the Antichrist talks about that time
period and um maybe uh our brother would
be interested in that absolutely just
call and ask it's called who is the
Antichrist that's the name of the lesson
the number is 8835 674 47 and you can
ask for it and we'll send it to you dial
pound 250 on your smartone name yeah and
say uh Bible answers live ask for that
study guide called who is the Antichrist
all right thank you and next caller that
we have is TC in Arizona TC welcome to
the
program thank you gentlemen I appreciate
it Pastor Doug and Pastor
John um my question is we celebrate
Jesus's birth every year in in winter
time but the Bible plainly states that
he was born during the first census
which would be in the fall why do we
celebrate even as Christians the birth
of Christ in the winter when he was born
in the fall well you're absolutely
correct uh there are three reasons in
the Bible and one you just stated from
history now of course we we know that
Mary and Joseph came down during the
census of Augustus Caesar or the date
for the census is not in the Bible but
the history does have that date and they
did not issue the census in the middle
of winter when people would be traveling
during the worst time of the year that's
say Shepherds of course were uh in their
fields they want to be in the fields in
the coldest time in Jerusalem or
Bethlehem uh and then it also tells us
that um Jesus began his ministry when he
was 30 he ministered three and A2 years
and he died in the Passover so he dies
in Spring you go back 33 and2 half years
that means he's born in the fall so it's
really clear that Christ was born we
don't know the date but sometime in the
fall so here's the question if a
Christian knows that he's born in the
fall we don't know exact date most of
the world is recognizing the birth of
Christ in
December and of course you know you go
to Southern Hemisphere December's hot it
depends on where you are some places
it's not a white Christmas so the real
question is um are are you supporting
paganism by doing it in a date that has
some Pagan trappings or um can you use
it as a witnessing opportunity because
the world is thinking about the birth of
Christ and exploit it for Christ to try
and make something good of it I'd say
that's one of those issues that a person
needs to just decide uh and feel
comfortable about it if they're grieved
that it's wrong don't do it you know I
think one of the things too about the
25th of December I think it's you know
we know Christ is not born on the 25th
of December and I don't think it's right
to treat that as a holy day or a sacred
day right but around that time of the
year where people are thinking about the
birth of Christ uh you know probably
good to take advantage of that and we do
a uh a concert around that time of the
year where we sing the Christmas carols
and we have the neighbors yeah invite
friends to come people are open to it at
that time of the year great opportunity
for sharing and witnessing and of course
it is a very significant event that
Jesus was born so there's nothing wrong
in singing about about it um but that
doesn't mean that there's something holy
about the 20 for 307 always feels a
little funny to preach about the birth
of Jesus in July yeah it would feel a
little it just feel like it's out of out
of sink somehow but nothing wrong with
that technically I don't know if that
helps we we do have a a book called
baptized paganism that talks about some
of the Pagan trappings of these things
and you might enjoy that TC the number
is 800 835
6747 and you can ask for the book it's
called baptized paganism
pound 250 on your smartphone say Bible
aners live and ask for that Anastasia is
in Canada welcome to the program
Anastasia hi pastors can you hear me yes
you do okay hi um my question is about
when Elijah was on Mount horb because he
FL he fled from Jezebel because she was
starting to kill him um okay so my
question is is that um who was in the
earthquake the fire and the wind if it
wasn't the Lord and I know there's a
deeper meaning to that story and I just
don't know what it is so can you explain
it to me yeah just for our friends
listening let me give you the background
so we understand the question Anastasia
is asking um Elijah gets frightened when
Jezebel threatens his life after this
Mount Carmel experience he ends up going
through the Wilderness all the way back
to Mount Si where Moses had gone and by
the way it's interesting that uh Moses
spent 40 days 40 40 nights up on Mount
Si Elijah spends 40 days and 40 nights
going to Mount Si and Jesus spends 40
days and 40 nights in the
wilderness and um up on the mountain the
Lord speaks to him and while he's there
there's an earthquake it says the Lord
was not in the earthquake and there's a
fire and the Lord was not in the fire
and there's a great wind and he says the
Lord is not in the wind but then there's
a still Small Voice and God is speaking
to him through the still Small Voice and
saying Elijah what are you doing here
and I think he's saying there that uh
sometimes you know we look for God to
speak through dramatic events and the
spirit typically speaks to us in a still
Small Voice Elijah had just come from a
fire coming down from heaven and the
slaughter of the prophets of Baal and a
great rainstorm after a drought and all
these and he's saying you know it's the
holy spirit that changes people's hearts
it's not going to be the Fire and Rain
you know I think absolutely Pastor I
just another thought on that he was
somewhat discouraged because he thought
he was the only one I mean already had
the mount Carl experience and then
Jezebel is threatening his life and he
was warning man am I the only one that
still worships the Lord and and God says
no I got 7,000 that haven't bowed the
knee to bail and we might not always see
God working but the spirit of God is
working and he's working in a powerful
way but maybe not with open display
sometimes there is I mean fire is also
symbol of the Holy Spirit the wind is
also symbol of the Holy Spirit but it's
through that still Small Voice through
the convicting voice of the spirit to
the conscience that lives are changed
yeah and he didn't need to be afraid of
an earthquake or fire or Mighty Wind if
God was with him and he didn't need to
be afraid of Jezebel that's right so
that was part of the message good
question appreciate that Anastasia all
right who's next we got Marlon in
Tennessee Marlon welcome to the
program oh hi uh Pastor hi Pastor Z and
Pastor dog B for taking my question told
my question uh I just Googled like uh
what does the bible uh think about or
behaving like or living like a sloth
yeah well the um the scriptures actually
have quite a bit to say about the
importance of work you know we talk from
time to time on the program about the
Sabbath and folks talk think about the
day of rest but part of that commandment
says six days Thou shalt work they
always think about that thou shalt not
work on the seventh day but they forget
Thou shalt work on the sixth days
so God wants us to uh be working and uh
you can read in Proverbs 18:9 he who is
slothful in his work is a brother to him
who is a great
destroyer and show me a man who is
diligent in his work Solomon says and he
will stand before Kings and not mean men
or men of low degree and so Bible has a
great deal to say about industry and um
being a worker and not to be lazy or
slothful the King James uses the word
slothful because of course a sloth is a
very slow moving creature and so it
became sort of a a metaphor for someone
who's lazy and here's the verse 2
Thessalonians 3:1 it says for if anyone
will not work neither shall he eat yeah
so yes it's good to work right it's good
to provide for your needs and needs of
your family so yep that's commendable in
scripture all right we got Susan
listening in South Carolina Susan
welcome to the
program thanks hey Pastor Doug and
Pastor John hope you're doing okay
tonight doing good thanks for call my
question is I had a customer ask me this
question the other day why did Adam wait
until after the fall to name Eve Eve he
called her woman in the beginning and
then after the fall he called her Eve
well I think he actually named her
before the fall uh it's not recorded
until after there but um Adam is the one
who named named all the creatures God
gives Eve to Adam or takes her from his
rib or makes her from the rib uh on the
sixth the day of creation and I'm I'm
assuming that he gave her her name
before the fall um we don't know the
fall may have happened a month after
creation he probably didn't wait a month
before he said what's your name by the
way you know you're my wife what's your
name so um I think it's just stating it
as after a fact that oh yeah by the way
the name that he gave to the woman was e
but the Bible often does that it it
gives the details later after the
headlines so any thoughts on that yeah
it's you know where Adam uh I think
where it talks about woman of course
when Eve came to Adam he said this is
now woman but then when God came looking
for Adam and Eve and uh God says you
know why are you hiding did you eat of
the tree I told you not to eat and then
he says well the woman that you gave me
he doesn't use her name Eve he says the
woman yeah and then of course afterwards
you discover yeah uh the reason her name
is Eve is because she's the mother of
everyone else right yeah she gave birth
to the human race from there on by the
way he calls her Eve before she's had
her first child right so I think she had
that name six day before yeah all right
great good question thank you first time
question yeah we' got Terry listening in
South Carolina Terry welcome to the
program hey Pastor D Pastor Ross how
y'all doing good thanks for taking my
call all right so my question is when do
you become specifically responsible for
a prophet's message um for example you
know John taught baptism but you
couldn't necessarily find that in the
Old Testament so what if I said you know
what I'm just going to keep taking my LS
to the temple and then you had the uh
instance where um he didn't perform any
Miracles and the other thing was say he
told his disciples hey this is the Lamb
of God that'll take away the sin of the
world then a couple weeks later he was
like hey can y'all go and check and make
sure that's the right gu so let's say I
was kind of on the fence and I was like
you know I like John but I'm just not
sure so what are y'all thoughts on a
situation like that as opposed to when
we can look and read everything and see
everything they did but what if you was
in real time and you had to make a
decision well it still happens even I'm
sorry yeah I was going to say it still
happens even in our time where truths
are presented that listen to and we may
be convicted and at what point uh are
you guilty for not responding when you
hear some new truth Pastor Ross and I do
evangelism as we're preaching we you
know preach things that people thought
well I've never thought about that
before and we can't be their conscience
but the way I understand it is once a
person understands a truth and the Holy
Spirit convicts him that it is truth
then they should not resist the voice of
the spirit I'm sure when John was
preaching the power of the spirit was
present in his preaching I mean the
crowds all swarmed out and Jesus even
said to the scribes and Pharisees you
know the message from John did it come
from God or from men because they they
didn't accept his preaching but the
people did they knew he was a prophet of
God so I think they had
evidence okay maybe time for one more uh
Maya we got about a minute uh welcome to
Bible answers live we need to make it
quick all right my question is is can we
observe the sabbath day and also go to
church on Sunday all right that's a good
we'll give you a quick qu answer to that
there's nothing wrong with going to
church seven days a week and our church
sometimes has a prayer meeting on
Wednesday so as far as going to church
or gathering together with Believers it
should be
done many times it says they broke bread
from house to house daily but as far as
what day is the Sabbath and you wouldn't
want to be treating another day like
it's the Sabbath or recognizing it that
way there's no question I I've been to
church on Sunday to worship with people
or to go to a Bible study but everyone
knows what I believe about the Sabbath
is the seventh day not the first hey
listening friends we're about out of
time for our almost conclusion of the
program we sign off and say goodbye to
our friends listening on satellite first
they're on a different time clock than
the other landbased stations the rest of
you don't go anywhere Pastor Rost are
and I are going to come back and do some
rapid fire Bible answers for the others
on satellite God bless till next
week thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California Hello friends and welcome
back to Bible answers live those of you
are able to stay by for the email
questions if if you have an email
question you want to send us is just
simply B questions at amazing facts.org
Pastor first question my son promised
that he would that he would never smoke
marijuana again but he broke his promise
if my son confesses will he be forgiven
or has my son son's probation closed
yeah so I think her son made a promise
to God and she and he broke it does that
mean that uh we're lost well let's hope
not because a lot of us have made the
best of intentions in a promise to God
every time a person's baptized they're
making sort of a covenant and um many
people have broken some of their
baptismal vows does that mean they've
committed the unpardonable sin God is
longsuffering and if you want evidence
for that look at what he did with Israel
right after he makes the first Covenant
they break the Covenant he could have
destroyed them Moses prayed for them God
says okay I'm going to give you another
chance well that acts out in people's
lives many times he was so patient with
the the children of Israel they
continued to test God and he forgave
them we got an example of Mary Magdalene
as well yeah she says cast out Seven
Devils that's right all right question
number two uh here we have Carly's
asking um what should I do if I'm
covered with tattoos and it's impossible
to get them removed well don't lose any
sleep over it um you know the Bible's
pretty clear it says uh you shall not
make cuting in your flesh or tattoo your
body I am the Lord um in the book of L I
us but a lot of people out there
especially in our day and age they're
you know tattooed high and low deep and
wide and then they get convicted they
read the Bible they come to the Lord you
can spend a lot of time and money and it
can be very painful to remove all your
tattoos I just say that you know you may
want to remove some just you know use
your use your good sense and do what uh
what you think the Lord wants you to do
but I don't think that God's going to
keep you out of Heaven if you came to
the Lord after you've gotten tattoos mhm
absolutely all right another question
can or do angels
die well Angels Are Spiritual creatures
that were created by God he can uncreate
them because um Bible tells us in
Revelation chapter 20 Satan and his
angels are cast in the Lake of Fire and
they are consumed it's a second death
and so yes those Fallen Angels they're
going to die they're kept right now in
Everlasting chains of Darkness for that
day all right Pastor Doug if a woman
represents the church in the Bible what
does a man represent he is the servant
of the
woman I you know not every time you find
woman doesn't mean church but in certain
times hey God bless friends we are out
of time we'll talk to you and study next
week bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible
[Music]
questions